as a high school student living in tokyo
your life is fairly normal
but that reality is upended after you
get
pulled into a different dimension
[Music]
another tokyo exists a post-apocalyptic
world
where angels and demons reside
suddenly you fuse with a mysterious
figure
gaining the power to fight demons
what lies ahead in this alternate realm
[Music]
the world is now transformed into a
sprawling demon-infested wasteland
though friendly demons do exist here
many are hostile
and will attempt to destroy you harness
your newfound powers to fight demons
using a command-based system
finding their weak point is key by
targeting it
the number of consecutive actions you
can perform in a combo will increase
though demons are formidable opponents
you may be able to recruit them via
negotiations
which begin when you open a conversation
with them
[Applause]
if a negotiation is successful a demon
will become a powerful ally
in some cases by rejecting a demon's
request
they may feel motivated and join you as
an ally
demons that do join will fight alongside
you and grow stronger
by fusing demon allies another demon
can be created
the newly fused demon's innate abilities
will vary
granting you a powerful ally customized
to your needs and play style
challenge the many demons roaming this
post-apocalyptic world
by harnessing the power of your own
what destiny will you choose
shin megami tensei 5 will launch
exclusively on nintendo switch november
12th
pre-orders for the physical version
begin june 21st
you